wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sapete qual è il nostro sogno è il
nostro sogno è fare qualcosa che duri
nel tempo che tocchi l'animo che stimoli
emozioni e sensazioni nelle persone nei
prossimi minuti vi spiegherò come ci
stiamo provando mi chiamo luca e insieme
a mio fratello silvio che oggi non è
potuto venire dal 2014 abbiamo deciso di
fare un grande cambiamento della nostra
vita professionale
abbiamo lasciato il lavoro e abbiamo
deciso di sviluppare un progetto che si
chiaman cycle di riutilizzo di un
materiale per noi di uso comune il
copertoncini bici da corsa facendo della
sostenibilità non solo un'attività
imprenditoriale ma anche un vero e
proprio stile di vita
questo viene dimostrato dai nostri
prodotti ma anche dal nostro laboratorio
dove sono presenti un giardino biologico
animali da giardino pannelli
fotovoltaici e dal prossimo anno stiamo
costruendo una banca di semi antichi per
promuovere una vita sostenibile a tutto
tondo
circolare ed auto alimentato
a fronte delle esperienze accumulate in
questi anni
voglio condividere con voi un uomo un
nuovo modello economico che fa della
circolarità un nuovo concerto
immaginate di essere un ciclista che la
domenica mattina o nel suo unico giorno
libero in questo un po mi rivedo si
sveglia all'alba sale in sella e
comincia a pedalare sente il suo corpo
che
esprime energia anche attraverso i
pedali viene trasmessa alle ruote
questo lo fa avanzare per le strade
magari nelle colline qua dietro o che
per la prima volta affronta il passo
dello stelvio
sapete quella salita che sembra
impossibile da scalare una volta che si
raggiunge la detta
l'emozione sale fa venir fuori un
sorriso sul volto
inspiegabile
quella sensazione che
è difficile da trasmettere o
veramente o da parlarne sapete io credo
che
il
raggiungimento dei propri traguardi che
tante volte ti fanno anche superare i
tuoi limiti personali
credo che sia una sensazione che ti
resta e ti resterà sempre dentro di te
ed è difficile anche parlarne o
trasmetterlo ad altri
dal far rivivere quella sensazione da
mantenerla in vita nasce di orta e
[Musica]
lo pneumatico che prima era solo fonte
di materiale di scarto diventa prezioso
diventa prezioso perché è il tuo
la consapevolezza che i tuoi km il tuo
sudore il sole caldo o la pioggia gelida
non possono essere né sostituiti nei
dimenticati perché quella sottile e
resistente e striscia di battistrada che
ti ha tenuto saldo al suolo
no non deve essere dimenticata perché è
unica è unica e nessun'altra sarà mai
uguale a quella su queste certezze
abbiamo costruito un
servizio sul nostro sito internet che
attraverso un customizzato re trasforma
il tuo copertoncini in ma non pensate lo
più come una ruota ma bensì immaginate
la lunghezza della sua circonferenza in
200 cm di materiale utilizzabile
quello che noi definiamo materia prima
secondaria
cioè
decontestualizzandolo dalla sua funzione
primaria
diamo il ciclista la possibilità di
costruire i propri accessori che
indubbiamente hanno dentro tutte le
emozioni e tutta la storia passata in
quella domenica mattina su quella strada
immaginate le possibilità di sviluppo
ad esempio poter trasformare quel
copertoncini in dieci portachiavi da
regalare ad amici o nipoti con il quale
hai fatto il giro in bici per l'italia
di svariati giorni o ancora di più poter
recuperare nel materiale di un
professionista magari che ne so un
un campione olimpico e poi trasformarlo
in una cintura autografata da mettere
all'asta e devolvere i proventi in
beneficenza
questo per noi vuol dire sognare
l'idea che
una persona che utilizza un prodotto e
come di consuetudine quando si deteriora
crea materiale di scarto
york times ha la possibilità di
essere il punto di rottura di
un'economia lineare basata sull'acquisto
usa e butta via e di fare il primo passo
cioè essere lui il primo passo per il
riutilizzo del proprio materiale
innescando così un processo di
sostenibilità diretto tra noi e lui dove
il raggio di questa circolarità è la
distanza tra il ciclista e cycle e
all'interno cioè il risultato sono dei
prodotti che hanno all'interno una
seconda vita dopo quella vissuta sulle
ruote che per assurdo so ancora più
vogliamo così dimostrare che una nuova
generazione di modelli di business è
possibile
crediamo che il concetto di
sostenibilità debba crescere dal basso
dove sia il cliente a scegliere
prediligere un prodotto sostenibile o in
economia circolare e quindi di
conseguenza anche le grandi aziende
produttrici dovranno adattarsi a questa
nuova consapevolezza
producendo prodotti già predisposti per
il loro riutilizzo
creando quindi valore e non materiale di
scarto
trasformando il rifiuto in materia prima
secondaria pronta per il proprio
l'utilizzo
un piccolo inciso mio fratello non è qui
perché in questi giorni siamo riusciti a
parlare con queste grandi aziende che ci
danno il
quella materia prima secondaria e
probabilmente il nostro sogno può
diventare realtà
[Applauso]